i need to find someone to fill in for
april
now i know i'm not going to find someone
who's both aggressively mean
and apathetic april really is the whole
package
i want to be your assistant really you
hate it here
so do you i'll make sure you don't have
to go to any meetings
if anyone comes to see you i'll scare
them away
wait april if you had to choose between
these two ties
you're hired i just figured
i might as well get paid for being here
ten months ago
she was an intern who could give a crap
about local government
now she's our newest employee to april
cheerios yay jerry come and celebrate
no thanks well everybody let's get back
to work
where are you going i want to talk to
ryan about the size of my desk
jerry you have to schedule an
appointment
okay how about now ron's not here he's
right there i i can see him
i'll let you know when he's available
and a girl parks and rec
confirming what that's not possible
oh no hey
good morning why are there six people
outside who say they're waiting to meet
with me
so you know how you love me because you
haven't had a single meeting with anyone
since i became your assistant
that's because every time someone calls
and requests a meeting with you
i always schedule it for march 31st why
because i didn't think march 31st
existed
30 days has september april march and
november
june and november today
is march 31st i know so
then how many meetings do i have today
93
okay okay well you know what to do
right to me this situation
is a blood-soaked nightmarish hellscape
however to leslie knope oh have fun
hey i thought i was having this meeting
with ron swanson
i'm afraid that ron swanson's currently
dead
oh i'm his daughter april swanson
and it's his last wish that i have this
meeting with you
there's no way this ordinance goes
through there's too much red tape um
this gridlock drives me nuts tell me
about it
yeah i think you're gonna have to make
an end run you know go right to the
commissioner on this one
you know what i hadn't thought of that
that is a really great idea yeah
i'm gonna do that okay your last resort
is probably gonna be city council
good luck there my thoughts exactly
i have no idea what i was saying how
many more meetings
20. april was supposed to be the moat
that kept the citizen barbarians away
from swanson castle
instead she blew up the castle and
stabbed me in the face
i hired you to do one thing
just one i don't care that you text all
day and sleep at your desk
in fact i encourage it but only because
you were doing that one
thing keeping this crap off my desk
give me five minutes before the next one
april did you call me
i did call you good ears chris's
assistant went
back to indianapolis so he's borrowing
me for a few days
yay i'd like you to get me some more
post-its i'd like them in multiple
colors
are that green i'd like yellow do not
buy orange
i do not want orange i have plenty of
orange got it
you want five million orange post-its
that's hilarious
oh what i have a post-it for you
this is a great job um great job
there you go
april could you come in here a second i
have a way to come in
great initiative you called me in listen
could you please call ann perkins
and tell her that i will be unable to
enjoy lunch with her today as i am just
swamped all day copy that
hi anne this is april i'm just calling
to let you know that chris can't make
lunch today
i knew you wouldn't care goodbye
april what are you doing here i work for
your boyfriend what are you doing here
i came to see why chris stood me up for
lunch but i think i just figured it out
because he doesn't like you no i'm
pretty sure it's not it actually it's
because i didn't call you
deliberately which if you ask me is a
fireable offense so
i would tell him that also he's not into
you sexually
ann perkins april ludgate literally two
of my favorite people
on earth i'm sorry that i had to cancel
lunch not at all it's not a problem
april here was very apologetic on the
phone she also sent me flowers
april nice touch
ann and i are headed out and i just
wanted to thank you
for everything today and i will see you
tomorrow
hi chris uh ron swanson has sent me over
to deliver to you this document
to whom it may concern dear chris there
is an emergency regarding the parks
department in april
may just be the only person who can help
i can't get into details because it's
super classified please release april
back to us permanently
god bless america love bert macklin
fbi what okay
well bye hey april listen
if you don't want to work for me i i'm
not going to force you you didn't have
to do this
she didn't do that that was i think
sounds like it was macklin's call
look i get it you're young and trying
isn't cool but i think you're smart i'm
gonna be going back to indianapolis soon
and i think you should come work for me
wow move all the way to indianapolis so
i can
pick up your vitamins and supplements
everybody start somewhere
you know travel and you will meet
interesting people
think about it okay i will
so i've been going over your reports
let's try to be consistent with our
fonts guys
okay there's a crazy amount of random
font differences in these memos
yeah people consistent font usage come
on
i actually think you look really good
except for the
stick up your butt what do you think
druid was it nathaniel
ellis man i feel like these interns do
not respect or like me
at all honestly you could loosen up a
bit on the font stuff
and everything in general elbow
el chupacabra drinking coffee
[Music]
what oh it's it's a
it's from 40 years ago never mind hey
that was
really fun this morning huh yeah yeah
yeah totally uh
oh wow look at that
did you draw that uh nope i didn't no no
no no it's really good i mean you're
a you're a great artist i can't do this
look i don't care who you're related to
i'm your boss and you can't keep
disrespecting me like this man
i didn't draw it your daughter did it
what her april's not my daughter she's
my friend does everyone think she's my
daughter
whatever point is she would never do
that to me
sorry dad
here's that report you wanted boss
it's funny because it has 30 different
fonts on it and you only like one
do you like it yeah it's hilarious
okay i'm sorry i drew those pictures of
you i was just messing around
you may not take this seriously but this
job is important to me
and by the way you should take it
seriously because i asked you to come
work here because i thought you'd enjoy
it
and i think you're smart but you have to
have some semblance of professionalism
and i need you to give like even a 15
effort
12 15. for god's sake i'm asking 15
effort it's not supposed to be a
negotiation fine i'm sorry
15.
you